and what you have is a a Islamic system
uh headed by what is known as a supreme
leader who claims to be not only you
know the Lord's anointed but actually uh
the Lord's representative on Earth and
uh if you're in that sort of situation
um it causes problems uh in terms of
governance because nobody's really
accountable he claims to be accountable
to God Alone the UN said that basically
Iran has every you know every possible
asset for industrial growth or something
you know expansion apart from good
governance and that's that's the big
weakness I mean it basically had
everything it's like you know a
revolution which you know gave its the
revolution is an Aladdin's cape and it's
proceeded to just basically spend it all
the memory of the last Revolution is now
fading a lot of people were horrified by
what the consequences of the first
Revolution were and weren't in a hurry
to have another one now the new younger
generation obviously have no memory of
revolution in 1979 and therefore a less
fearful the distinctive thing this time
around is that the protest is overtly
political in it's led by the young and
it's led by women and certainly the
protesters now are not thinking about
reforming things you know it's not about
tweaking aspects of these our Republic
they just want it gone I think people
are basically coming to the conclusion
that internal reform is impossible and
that the only thing ahead of them is
really for a complete transformation of
the state I mean in Iran
this is not the first time a woman has
been brutalized so you know people would
say well you know why would this trigger
off well it would trigger something
because at this time you know there
comes a time when people say enough
foreign
[Music]
of using bulky old wallets giving you a
bulge where you don't want it to be my
old wallet was massive so it brought all
the ladies to the yard which was a huge
distraction and got in the way of my
esteemed work on trigonometry reg
wallets have an incredible solution for
you this is mine Sleek stylish and with
an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anthem has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Ridge are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantin kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our fantastic
guest today is the perfect person to
talk to about the subject we want to
discuss is a British Iranian historian
at St Andrews University Ali I'm sorry
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me it's a real pleasure to have
you before we start talking about Iran
it's a subject that a lot of our
audience have asked us to cover uh tell
everybody who are you how are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us
well um as you noted I'm British your
audience I came here uh During the
Revolution as a young lab being sent
over to school here and uh basically
stayed uh for Fairly obvious reasons and
uh pursued my education here and uh
ended up uh becoming an academic really
an academic working uh on Iran I thought
I might as well do something where I had
some linguistic ability so um that that
helped I think and I've been studying
researching writing about Iran for
probably about 30 years which is uh way
too long really and I'm now and I've
been at the University of surroundings
actually where I founded an Institute
for Iranian studies back in 2006 so but
I've been here yeah the university since
2004. which is why as I say you're the
perfect person to talk to about this and
Ali as you know on trigonometry uh we we
like to explore the broader issue rather
than just going to the news headlines
that are out right now so right now I
think a lot of people are in the
position where they were with Ukraine
where it's like well something's
happening no one knows what it is most
people couldn't find the country on the
map uh don't know the history and I'm
certainly in terms of Iran very much in
that place myself I don't really know
anything about it uh can you talk to us
about the you know the broad you know
obviously there's a lot of history we
could cover and in an hour probably not
going to get to all of it but I suppose
the big question is how are we where we
are today how has this happened take us
all the way through to you know over the
last many decades well I mean as a
historian I have to say I mean you
you've uh you've given me a a bit of an
Open Door there to to talk a great
length about the historical roots of
this I will limit myself however in
order to get through in the time that we
have two you know a couple of sort of
major themes about the Islamic
revolution itself and the fact that
obviously it was a contested Revolution
at the time in 1979 there were two very
very different ideas as is You Know Not
Unusual in these things about where the
revolution should go uh summed up really
in the the title of the new state the
Islamic Republic so the Islamic Republic
was basically composed of two wings of
thought one that thought actually the
aims and Ambitions of the Revolution
should be to establish a Republic and
the other side which eventually won out
that basically said no the ambition
really is to establish an Islamic State
of sort that the Republic was really a
means to an end uh and that the popular
participation votes and so on and so
forth were well you know not vital
um so what we've ended up having really
is that one wing of the revolution
triumphed over the other and that Wing
is really an autocratic islamist Wing
Around the person of a supreme leader
and as you can imagine that sort of uh
autocratic tendency has tended to go
against the grain of what most Iranians
are actually interested in the
constitution of the Islamic Republic did
enshrine a number of sort of Rights for
people not a huge amount but certainly a
you know a limited amount that might
have been seen as valuable as by most
Iranians but most of these have been
crushed and instead what you have is a a
Islamic system headed by what is known
as a supreme leader a a guardian
the guardianship of the jurist is the
term that they use in Persian but it's
basically the supreme leader
um who claims to be I mean this is where
it gets a little bit pre-modern I have
to say who claims to be not only you
know the Lord's anointed but actually uh
the Lord's representative on Earth and
if you're in that sort of situation
um it causes problems uh terms of
governance because nobody's really
accountable
he claims to be accountable to God alone
and of course this has led to huge
frictions it's led to huge frictions in
terms of the way in which the country is
governed it's led to huge corruption and
frictions in terms of the political
economy of the country and what we've
seen over the last I would say decade to
15 years is a series of protests that
have emerged against this
autocracy and they've been growing in
intensity and frequency so while a lot
of people as you quite rightly say we'll
probably look at this and say you know
what the hell is happening this has all
taken us a little bit by surprise to
those of us actually been watching
around it it hasn't really I mean it's
it's something that most people
anticipated because the situation was
just getting worse
um the regime was entering what we might
call a deteriorating cycle and uh the
last protest they had was in 2019 it was
pretty violent violently suppressed
um and things have just got worse the
distinctive thing this time around is
that the protest is overtly political
it's led by the young and it's led by
women and there is a deep deep
ideological divide in golf now between
uh the protesters and the authorities
and neither side wants to compromise and
certainly the protesters now are not
thinking about reforming things you know
it's not about tweaking aspects of these
aren't Republic they just want it gone
so you know things are much much more
serious this time around so it's it's an
attempted Revolution at this point it
sounds like what you're saying right I
think people are basically coming to the
conclusion that internal reform is
impossible and that the only thing ahead
of them is really for a complete
transformation of the state and
therefore they just you know they view
it as revolutionary now of course you
know when we look at things like
revolutions uh it's very difficult to
you know predict the outcome of these
things it's very difficult to know
whether it's revolutionary my own view
by the way as a student of Iran is that
Iran has been in has had revolutionary
conditions for some time uh the question
is is whether these could be you know
operationalized in the way or whether
you know that conjunction of events
takes place to to trigger these things
off
my assumption always was that the
government would all would end up doing
something pretty stupid and which would
trigger something so you know if you go
back to the Arab Spring you know I mean
I always said to people you know the
problem with these political upheavals
is they're not predictable you know who
knew that in Tunisia a local Trader was
going to self-immolate and Trigger off
that whole sort of serious protest well
I mean in in Iran
this is not the first time a woman has
been brutalized so you know people would
say well you know why would this trigger
off well it would trigger something
because at this time you know there
comes a time when people say enough
and Ali has this got the has this got
the popular Groundswell of people behind
this movement or is it is it very much a
kind of a young person thing a
university educated people who are
rising up against them because I've got
Iranian friends and they say actually a
lot of the poorer people are very much
more conservative they're very much more
religious and there's a tends to be a
lot more support for the government from
these these more poorer communities
I mean I don't think that's true anymore
I have to say uh that's always been the
tendency that uh you know the the poorer
rural communities or some in the sort of
more Shanty Town aspects will be
conservative with a small sea or
actually even conservative of the large
sea and really support the government
the fact is that actually even if you
look at 2019 a lot of the violence uh
perpetrated against people in Iran was
done against these very you know much
poorer communities a lot of the protests
were protests that had economic uh
reasons behind them pretty you know
brutal economic reasons actually I mean
the level of poverty is is extraordinary
and the poor you know really have
nothing to lose anymore what's happening
this time around I think you're quite
right is of course that a lot of this is
also being led by you know while I don't
like to use these sort of terms like
lower and middle class and others I
think you know in Iran the class system
is very simple there are the rulers and
then there are the rules I mean that's
basically it they have various different
levels of wealth but those who are
within that political fraternity are
enormous wealthy I mean I don't know if
any of you see this sort of Rich Kids of
Tehran sort of Instagram accounts and
stuff it's it's extraordinary I mean
it's pretty obscene you know uh but the
vast majority of people struggle
um now what you can say is there's sort
of like a professional educated class
that's true and those who go to
university and those obviously who are
the manual laborers but actually I think
the level of protest this time around
basically crosses that divide I mean
it's it's it's a whole broad range and
this is what's quite interesting and
particularly now uh what's been
distinctive actually
um is the level of support from what we
could term The Wider uh political and
social Hinterland
and what I mean by that and you'll have
noticed hopefully uh you may have
noticed if you're watching the Iran
England match certainly that among
sporting uh uh you know artists sporting
celebrities and others there is a lot of
sympathy and support for this this
movement so how I've described it really
is that yes the individuals out on Pro
you know doing the sort of physical
protesting might be as a proportion of
the population relatively small I mean
of course it is it always is in these
protests there's a sort of a Vanguard
but the hinterland the supporting
Hinterland is is vast and and this is
what's problematic uh for the regime you
know the regime knows that it's almost
fighting a guerrilla warfare with uh a
group of people who are very well
supported by a sympathetic society that
authors utterly fed up with what's been
going on and Ali how much of this has to
do with uh U.S restrictions against Iran
and the and and the embargoes that are
happening is this partly to do with the
fact that people are struggling so badly
they they can't eat they can no longer
function so
the death of this poor woman has just
lit the flame to essentially a pile of
grievances that have been building up
for many a year
well I think there's a there's a sort of
a
um a narrative if I can put it that way
that tends to see everything that
happens in Iran as a consequence of U.S
actions and U.S sanctions in particular
U.S sanctions I've always said and
sanctions in general and this is the way
I've described it are salt rubbed into a
very large self-inflicted wound and that
self-inflicted wound is political and
economic mismanagement on a grotesque
scale and what's interesting is most
Iranians in Iran understand that so
they're obviously not enamored with big
sanction I mean I think they're the most
sanctioned country in the world right I
mean they sort of mock the Russians for
complaining that they're sanctioned they
say you haven't seen anything yet yeah
on the other hand you know if you look
at you know the views that are expressed
among Iranians almost all of them say
that we know where the source of our
problems are you know the source of our
problems is a government that is
inherently corrupt
and you know had they managed the
country's resources better then you know
we wouldn't be in the situation we're in
and let me give you one example of what
I mean by that because you know there's
a lot of talk about you know what Trump
did maximum pressure so on and so forth
one of the great tragedies of modern
Iran is the fact that they're running
out of water okay so any historian of
Iran will tell you that the Iranian
plateau is not short of water actually
in terms of its water resources but the
rainfall always falls in the wrong
places so what you need to do in order
to irrigate you need you need to have
good water management
what's happened in the last 40 years is
not only is the population I think
probably tripled almost tripled doubled
two and a half basically but they you
know they they wanted to gave an eye
there's been
a drawing down of those Water Resources
um a huge use of again of of of water to
to supply Agricultural Development you
know pistachios and stuff take a huge
amount of water and the water table in
Iran has has basically depleted
and in 2017 and 2019 in particular you
saw that large stretches of Southern
Iran
just didn't have any running water I
mean it's just it's a catastrophe I mean
it's an absolute catastrophe and I have
talked to environmentalists in Iran who
were just distressed by this I mean
really badly distressed
this has nothing to do with Western
sanctions or you know or this this is
basically to do with poor governance I
mean it's as simple as that and and the
trouble is you know if you look at it uh
through and through you'll see that yes
there is impoverishment but where does
this impoverishment come from it comes
fundamentally from uh the the the
corruption and political mismanagement
that's at the heart of this regime
and and one of the things that I think a
lot of us find quite striking about this
situation is uh you obviously came here
during the the revolution yeah uh and I
was born shortly after but just to think
that certainly within your lifetime and
almost within my lifetime you know you
see these photos of women walking around
in Iran uh Dressed sort of like Western
women you know you don't have a
religious police uh in in the way that
you have now all of this uh it must be
an extraordinary transformation for for
a country to go through and I imagine
the memory of the fact that things don't
have to be the way that they currently
are lives on for many people even though
it is the young people who are
protesting how has that that played out
in this in this whole scenario so there
are two things about that which I think
are quite important one is that the
Islamic Republic always used to uh brag
about the fact that while its economic
record was not great at least his
political record was better than what
happened in the last years of the Shah
so in the last two of the show the
economic record was pretty good but it
was politically the political
environment was quite suffocating so
people would always say that you know
yes politics isn't brilliant and the
Islamic Republic but it's better okay
now they don't really have that I mean
they neither have the politics or the
economics and everyone can look back in
the 1970s and say actually
economically our International standing
our economic standing whatever the
problems they were politically uh was
actually vastly better I mean you know
and social life was also advisory I mean
politics was was constrained but nobody
interfered with your with your social
life basically so people had that now
one of the aspects and and the Iranian
government the Islamic Republic gets
very very anxious about these satellite
television channels that largely based
in London has happened
um that broadcast all these films into
Iran
and there's always you know at the
moment they're obsessed with you know
it's always BBC Persian Iran
International all these sort of things
and they all say these are foreign
interference actually what a number of
these channels including and I should
mention manotel so manulture and Iran
International have done two uh to the
channels based in London who what they
have actually done
is they pumped into the country
broadcasting the country documentaries
historical documentaries about Iran in
the 20th century using huge number I
mean an enormous amount of archival
material I don't have a clue how they
managed to get hold of all this I have
to say but they got it
and because obviously this archival
material shows you know the Shah and the
empress and whatever and people you know
wandering around the streets all you
know wearing you know basically Western
you know style clothes but also a
certain degree of sort of international
standing the Shah also spoke very good
English she spoke very good french you
know he could communicate with people
and people look at this so it's not
memory so much it's almost like a re an
implanted memory if I can put it that
way because obviously these young people
have no memory of what goes on 1977 no
idea but what they get now is they get
this sort of
they almost reminded of something that
they you know their their parents would
have said you had you know
and it looks good I mean for them it
looks good so I think this has had an
enormous impact and I said this years
ago I said uh forget all these political
programming and you know news programs
young people aren't probably watching a
lot of this but what they are probably
watching are documentaries about
I don't know you know Reza or Muhammad
or the progress the country made I mean
there was a great great documentary for
instance uh done a few years ago on the
Iran Iraq war but basically the vast
majority of documentary was the lead-up
to the Iran Iraq war and it had the
whole negotiations between the Shah and
Saddam Hussein lots of extraordinary
footage
um
you know it was a bit of an eye-opener
for a lot of people when they saw this
because they wouldn't have been familiar
to it I mean you have to remember this
as a society in Iran that doesn't teach
history in the way that we we would
understand it they don't have that
history what they have is a very very
sort of political history in the way
that you might have seen in the Soviet
Union you know I did I did and that's
one of the things I was gonna ask you
Ali because I think uh we in the west
also probably don't know the history of
Iran very well of course you do but most
of us have no idea and I think you know
forgive me but to most people in the
west Iran is a is a small country far
far away yeah that's insignificant
irrelevant yes but actually it's a
descendant of a great Empire in the
Persian Empire uh the center of Shia
Islam in the world uh and a hugely oil
rich country which is very powerful in
the region and and not just in the
region I mean we see right now Russia
buying Iranian Weaponry in order to fine
in Ukraine so what is the significance
of all of this more broadly because I
think we might would I be right in
saying that we massively underestimate
the significance of Iran in the West
I you know I have to say I think in the
popular conception you're absolutely
right because Iran really since 1979 has
faded from you know the the uh uh the
the popular sort of uh stare or
imagination whichever you want to call
it
um I think prior to that that wasn't the
case I mean the Iranians had a fairly
sort of uh positive image in the West
um
probably to the detriment of the shot
has to be said but nevertheless it it
did and you know obviously since 1979
the image of Iran has has been has taken
a a deep turn south I mean it's it's not
done well at all but there's a lot of
sympathy I have to say among uh people
in the west including the United States
by the way for for Iran or Persia I mean
I often use Persia a lot in my in my
discussion because it gives it it it it
connects with people you know in a way
that Iran doesn't and
um you know I have to point out this is
the same country I mean with Persia is
just the name that the Western countries
used to call the country Iran until you
know until the 20th century
um but it makes that historical
connectivity and I think by right you
know Iran and the region should be the
economic motor of the Middle East I mean
by rights I mean if if it if it got his
act together uh there was a study done I
think many years ago I think by the U.N
the UN said that basically Iran has
every you know every possible asset for
industrial growth or something you know
expansion apart from good governance and
that's the
weakness I mean it basically had
everything out of water it had the you
know human capital you know resources
natural resources has huge amounts and
of course you mention oil but the great
you know the great sort of unspoken
thing is it does have actually have the
second largest reserves of natural gas
in the world and none of this has been
touched you know so for instance you'll
see today that people say you know is
doing very well through because it has
access to this gas reserves actually
that gas field it has is shared with
Iran I mean it's not you know so it's
not it's not that as gas field but of
course Qatar is exploiting it obviously
and Iran isn't because nobody's
interested in investing in Iran so the
hoodie does anything in Iran uh and it
does have these enormous uh it has an
enormous capacity as someone said you
know to be the Japan of the Middle East
you know to basically lead that economic
growth uh but it's you know it's a
tragedy really the last 40 years it's
really squandered that opportunity here
so yes you know my view and this is
again an argument that I have is that
the way the what the Islamic Republic
has done is it has inherited the
architecture of the modern state from
the pallavis so the panavi dynasty
ruling you know from the 1920s through
to 1979 basically built the state they
built the modern state
imperfectly but nonetheless they built
it
um it was By 1979 pretty rich it was the
largest producer in OPEC by the time by
the way larger than Saudi Arabia I mean
Iran basically lost its lead because of
the revolution
and
um
you know it was you know a big investor
actually in in the west as well I mean
this this isn't I mean the Shah had lots
of money I mean the Shah was one of the
people who was behind the oil price
shock of 1973. people forget that by the
way because they will see it as the Arab
or you know embargo but actually it was
the Shah that really pushed it by the
end of 73 and there was huge amounts of
money
um and Iran's standing was you know was
pretty positive again I'm not saying
without problems so what the Islamic
Republic did is it inherited that and
it's basically gutted it essentially you
know so it's basically inherited this
huge resource and spent it it's it's
it's it's like you know a revolution
which you know gave its the revolution
it was an Aladdin's cape and it's
proceeded to just face he spend it all
what it hasn't done is reinvest and and
that's the problem I mean that is the
problem and even if you look at Iran's
oil wells by the way they're lucky they
lack investment I mean they lack
investment they're running out
um they need to be maintained in a
proper way and they just aren't uh
because obviously of the sanctions but
also because of Iran's relations with
the West most of the companies that
would be able to do the work that Iran
needs to have done a western
um yes the Chinese come in now and then
but the you know the Iranians also also
a bit sniffy about the Chinese to be
honest I mean they sort of think that
the best equipment is Western
so I mean there's this wonderful you
know schizophrenic attitude towards the
west of course they want Western
technology they want Western uh
expertise but you know the ideology
loads the West so it's it's and I always
say to them I say you know they say why
are the Americans you know why why is
our why are our relations I mean I'll
tell you this anecdote I remember a guy
coming up to me and saying uh you know
we've got to reduce tensions to the
United States and I said well this is
back in 2007 by the way and I said well
you know it would help if you stop
saying death to America every Friday
and they uh and he looked at me I mean
he looked at me in a sort of slightly
you know slightly gormless way I have to
say and said but you know Dr Ansari it's
part of our culture and I said well if
it's part of your culture mate you know
there's not much I can do about it you
know I mean this is you know this is the
absurdity of it on the one hand they
want to be friends but they don't seem
to get it that if you just Heap abuse on
people every two minutes it's not gonna
work
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
well this is what I was going to ask you
Ali because I think uh we in the west
were Keen to be self-reflective we're
always Keen to you know find our flaws
and our faults yeah so uh as again super
Layman question but why are we
sanctioning around where does that come
from is it simply the Revolution was
seen as illegitimate or what are the
reasons for because the story you're
telling is actually a very sad story
it's a country of uh tremendous
potential great riches uh the people
that I've met who are Iranian are
extremely well educated very intelligent
uh it's a country with great potential
that is handicapped by the fact that
it's been taken over by these primitive
backward religious fundamentals
essentially that's what you're saying
and we have these tensions with Iran at
a time when you know if it was ruled by
different people with whom we didn't
have those tensions you know that gas
that oil that influence in the region
might have actually been very helpful to
to some of of what we want so why why is
there this tension between us and Iraq
well I mean the immediate I mean there
are two stories and we ought to mention
the more historical you know aspects but
the immediate cause of course is the
hostage crisis in 1979 so you know
obviously the taking of the U.S embassy
in in November 1979 and they're keeping
them you know the diplomats hostage for
444 days uh had a fairly bad impact in
the United States but you've got to add
to that by the way the your own Contra
scandal in 1984 or so you know which all
came out so both Democrats and
Republicans in America have bad
experiences with Iran the Iranians of
course will
claim that all this is down to 1953 and
the coup that was launched by the
British and the Americans against the
then nationalist prime minister Moss out
there you know they they all like to
sort of point to a point of origin an
original sin that causes all the
problems
um and I you know I don't think we
probably don't have time to go into all
the details of the history I mean what
all I would say is a lot of these are
politically General I mean a lot of
these are genuine historical issues that
need to be discussed and properly
scrutinized but in terms of the way
they're used analytically these are
political issues you know the Russians
did far worse things to Iran to be
honest over the last 150 years and yet
funnily enough there's you know the
official ideology is very pro-russian
okay so it's not you know it's not an
issue but you know in a in in popular
culture and certainly popular political
culture in Iran today in a 1953 looms
very large so they'll claim that that's
the reason we have an enmity with the
United States that said the sanctions
issue is really a product in 1979 the
decline in relations really that emerged
in the 1980s although while sanctions
were placed on Iran at the time I mean
when I used to go to Iran in the 1990s
and the early 90s yes Iran was a
sanctioned country but it wasn't heavily
sanctioned yeah I mean there were
restrictions on U.S business in Iran in
particular I think fairly misguided to
be honest it in those stages but it was
driven by that sort of the enmity that
American politicians had for Iran for
the reasons that I've outlined but you
know you could buy American Goods in in
Iran I mean it wasn't it wasn't
difficult to do because they all got
came through Dubai anyway and all this
sort of thing and it was possible when
the real tough sanctions really came out
was the end of the 19 uh
I I suppose
partly in in in the end of the mid 1990s
end of the night time but the really
really tough sanctions came really with
Obama uh when and and also a bigger part
and really prior to that with the
nuclear issue when the nuclear issue
became very prominent in the early in
the early 2000s sanctions begin to pile
on but again the really tough ones
coming around 2011 2012 and that's under
the Obama Administration where they use
sanctions really to try and twist Iran's
arm to get them to the negotiating table
over their nuclear issue and I mean that
has also different you know there are
different problems with that because
sanctions becomes almost an end in
itself in terms of handling Iran and the
nuclear process becomes basically the
the synchronon of Iran policy so
everything is driven and focused by
getting a nuclear resolution a
resolution to the Iran's nuclear program
irrespective of what the collateral
damage might be to wider Iranian Society
or what's going on in why do Iranian
Society I mean this this is the problem
so there's a whole narrative that's
built up in there that
um
is also quite destructive
um I think to our understanding I mean
one of the problems that people are
surprised by the demonstrations that
have happened now is because almost all
Western analytical energy has been
devoted to a solution to the nuclear
crisis and everything else that's
happened in Iran is secondary to that
and and that's been a a flaw I think in
the way we've approached the country but
certainly you know the origins of the
current situation is really the hostage
crisis and like to subject I mean that's
that's basically it
Ali I'm really glad that you've raised
the issue of the nuclear crisis because
the stories are starting now to filter
into the mainstream media the Iran are
actually quite close to being able to
produce nuclear weapons yeah and so how
does that affect our relationship now
with Iran is it do you think that we're
just going to keep applying the pressure
and and hopefully by doing that
is this is this regime out of power well
does it I mean it in in policy terms
it's enormously difficult you know for
reasons so you have a country basically
an open revolt
you have another policy that seeks to
get a resolution of the nuclear crisis
which will then see the release of funds
to the very regime that's shooting its
own people which obviously the optics
for that are not great in the capitals
of Europe and Washington right so you
you face a very very difficult problem
but then of course you know this idea
that are the Iranians ramping up
enrichment which they have been now when
you say are they close to building a
bomb I mean people say it's really a
question of have they got enough
enriched uranium in order to pursue the
construction of a bomb
I'm a little bit more skeptical about
how close they are to building a bomb I
have to say I mean I I think there's it
will take time for them to actually
develop that and then obviously they
need to test it I mean where they're
going to test it I don't know
particularly but anyway so of course
they've claimed that they never would go
down that route I mean I'm going to be
fairly cynical about these claims but
you know some people in the west have
believed it
um but nonetheless I think at the moment
uh we're probably slightly further away
to Iran actually developing a workable
device than people think
um that's my view although I should say
you know if you happen to get a a
nuclear expert odd he'll tell you
otherwise I will defer to them but
that's my my reading of the situation
um and that of course you know the other
pressures that the West can put on Iran
at this time uh will probably help to
prolong that process if I can put it
that way you know they they they're not
they're not at ease it's not like they
it's not like the JCP has been
implemented we're now the sunset Claus
is coming in and they can pursue it you
know basically in the full glaze of you
know a western tolerance I think about
it that way I mean obviously the west
and the Israelis in particular are not
going to look on this very very
favorably now the other dimension of
this which I think is important which
people miss out on really is the fact
that
um Iran has also doubled down on its
political military and ideological
relationship with Putin and is probably
as as Constantine was saying earlier you
know having supplied you know Russia
which is a very bizarre turn of events I
have to say uh it doesn't not a great
look for Putin but uh there you are you
know he's he's taking his drones at the
moment I think he's past caring about
here
I think it's yeah but it you know I have
to say you know so this time last year
you know my my own uh view was always
that you know Russia took the view and
Putin took the view that he he sort of
mentored the Iranians you know you guys
are revolutionary and and fairly rabid
about it at times but hey you know I can
handle International politics you know
I'll you know I'll use my Vita at the UN
and so and so forth actually you know
judging by what's happened in the last
six months I have to say you know summer
Putin's rhetoric could have been written
for him in Tehran I mean it's really
quite extraordinary stuff I mean it's
very religious uh very millenarian
and this is the Striking thing though
what it does of course is it means that
the protests in Iran become part of a
wider problem and this is quite
interesting for me I haven't fully
understood or fully sort of thought in
my mind what the implications of this
are but I think there are implications
certainly in Western chances and others
where they look at this they see the
problem in Iran not as a sort of a
particular problem for Iran but they see
the problems in Iran and the fighting
Iran is part of a wider struggle that's
going on you know vis-a-vis Ukraine and
Russia as well and of course zelenski
has made this point very very clearly I
mean he's also you know he's he's
wonderful sort of PR person for the
protesters in Iran in a sense he's now
saying look you know our struggle is one
you know so I think this has a much much
deeper uh implications and consequences
for Iran because the idea that
um you know the Western powers are going
to sign up to deal with Iran
um has become even less likely given
Iran's support for Putin I mean it just
it it you know there might have been a
possibility previously you know some
sort of arrangement I mean it's been
done before the West has not always been
absolutely terribly good at sticking to
its ideals but now it just becomes
enormously difficult
um and and I should add by the way if as
we expect Putin loses ultimately in
Ukraine it will have tremendous knock-on
effect in in Iran itself I mean I I
think that it'll Rebound in Iran it will
empower the protesters as well and ali
um what role does Israel play in all of
this because obviously Iran has has been
incredibly antagonistic to Israel
has has uh the have the Israelis managed
to apply a lot of pressure onto the
United States because they're portraying
the israelians quite rightly as
aggressors towards them and that meant
that the embargoes as sanctions have
have been harsher as a result
I think you know the Israelis I mean one
of the interesting things about the
recent protests is actually Iranian Aya
and and and anger is really being
directed towards Saudi Arabia rather
than Israel which is quite striking
normally they would always blame Israel
for everything I mean it it's all like
you know knee-jerk reaction and you know
for the Iranians certainly the Iranians
and this is the fascinating thing I mean
for the Iranians of the in the regime
you know Israel is an ideological
problem I mean they always they try to
describe as a geopolitical problem it
isn't it's an ideological problem you
know and they're constantly talking
about you know we're going to eliminate
Israel Israel will collapse I mean I
either in a sort of very passive
aggressive Voice or just an aggressive
voice I mean it's one of the two
um and obviously the Israelis are
extremely you know justifiably anxious
about all this so I mean I do think the
Israelis at times have not helped uh
their own cause I don't think Netanyahu
played played it brilliantly
um on the other hand you know what
they've been able to do is is is really
play the bad cop to summon the in Europe
for the good cop I mean I think it's
it's very much a sort of a a combined
effort and they're able to keep the
West's feet to the fire on this issue
and remind them that you know given they
live in the region they have a very
serious take on what happens so I think
in terms of intelligence I think in
terms of combating certainly in proxies
I mean basically the Israelis and the
Iranians are already basically fighting
in Syria but I mean that's you know the
these things already started you know
the Israelis pay an absolutely pivotal
role in basically keeping a light Shone
on this and I think that's you know
that's vital I mean and they they're
reminding the West that you know you
guys might be sitting back and and
thinking about you know Wonderful deals
but at the end of the day we are the
ones who have to pieces and pick up the
consequences so it has to be something
that we can live with and I think really
during Obama's period of course the
deals that were being addressed were not
something really the Israelis felt
comfortable with
um I mean Iranians as a whole by the way
their relationship with Israel is is
much more uh if I may say so sort of
relaxed I mean they they don't have an
issue with the Israelis I mean there's
usually some huge numbers of Iranian
Jews of course
and many of whom I have to say uh uh are
in are in Israel at the moment
um and you know there are strong
cultural links I mean and I said to
someone I said you know I think I think
there are only two countries in the
world possibly three that have this sort
of obsession with Cyrus the Great you
know one is Iran the other is Israel you
know and possibly America by the way but
certainly in Israel they're really sort
of keen on South great and there was a
there was a
a phoning show many years ago which was
a very I mean summed it up for me
actually in some ways and it was
obviously Israeli you know Persian
television in Israel and they were
talking about Iran and then they had
this phone call from Iran you know so
everyone got a little bit tense you know
and and the guy
on the phone call actually started out
quite aggressive on the phone call you
know you guys you know where the hell
you know and all this and yeah I think
the studio audience was a little bit
well you know maybe we should cut this
guy off and basically the conclusion
this guy was he sort of said you know he
said two and a half thousand years ago
you know Cyrus the Great liberated you
look from Babylon until when the hell
are you going to send someone to
liberate us from the current you know
and of course the whole thing just and
that sort of spilled over and I thought
it was a great sort of uh you know the
attitude in Iran among Iranians uh
towards uh the Israelis is is
is much less toxic than you'll find in
this order I mean they're bored with the
ideology to be honest and you know they
don't forget that actually you know uh
the relationship with Israel prior to
the Revolution was actually pretty
positive
that is such an interesting point and I
think it comes back to to I was going to
ask you something about because people
say to me well you know you're from
Russia surely you know the Russian
people are going to get fed up of
Vladimir Putin and overthrow him and
install brilliant wonderful liberal
democracy and I'm like
why why would they do that they've never
had democracy uh in the entire history
of the country they've never had this
thing that they're supposed to be
aspiring to now
um but with Iran it sounds like actually
there was a history of things not I mean
you it wasn't an Islamic Republic of the
type that it is now before so How likely
is it that you know these protests are
successful in
forcing genuine change and
transformation and you get a a leap of
some kind forward backwards left right
whatever in a different direction where
you end up with an Iran that that has a
completely different posture towards the
world and is welcome back into the
International Community
well that's a really good I mean it's a
really good point in in the sense of you
know what are the prospects for you know
change in Iran in that sense and you
know as you say if you look at the
Russian experience you know what the
transition to democracy is never
something that should be taken for
granted uh and these are difficult
what I would say is this of course that
first of all I'd say that culture Iran
has a very very positive
um there's a receptive audience in the
west let me put it that way I mean
there's no that you you know actually to
be honest I always say Saudi Iranians
just allow people to call you Persia and
you'll find actually that branding is
going to work wonderfully and you know
all people will talk about is carpets
and caviar cats and this other thing and
you know you're immediately soften your
image but I I use that sometimes as
students also just to point out you know
how word association you know how
important it is in a way and how
branding is important because also to
point out you know in the west if you
talk about these things there are
positive connotations to that and people
will sort of build on it now in the
political sense and this is something I
have been uh harping on about really is
that you know a lot of people will be
fighting the last Revolution of course
and looking at 1979 as the model for
anything going forward
I I've said that actually what people
really need to look at is 1906 and 1906
was Iran's constitutional Revolution
which set up you know basically a
parliamentary system on the British
model okay uh and it you know obviously
didn't work uh in in the long term but
it set the template and this is
important it set a reference point for
every subsequent political movement and
even to this day you know younger people
come up and they say what happened to
the aspirations of that movement of that
revolution in 1906 why have we not
promised you know why has that promise
not being delivered and I think that's
in some ways quite important I'm one of
these people and one of these historians
I have to say who who actually believes
in the power of ideas that change things
and yes it can take a long time for
these ideas to seep in and yes it can
take you know it can have a troubled
Journey if you can put it that way but
the fact is one of the things about the
current movement is that you know 15
years after probably the most systematic
you know rutant Branch suppression that
occurred in Iran after the green
movement in 2009 a whole new generation
of Iranians have come up you know many
of them Teenagers by the way
expressing exactly the same views in a
way over pre you know of a previous
generation and talking about rights you
know people say it's about the veil it's
not about the veil it's about the right
to choose if you want to wear the veil
wear it if you don't want to wear the
whale don't wear it but there's a fact
that people in Iran men women Baha'is
religious minorities of other sorts
whatever you want to talk about ethnic
minorities have rights that protect them
you know and have civil and human rights
and these are very very fundamental
uh ideas you know that come you know I
think have been best achieved in a way
and expressed in the western context but
certainly have deep deep roots in in
many different cultures uh and were
expressed very clearly you know 100
years ago and the fact that they were
expressed very clearly 100 years ago in
Iran shows that they have deep you know
they have deep roots and it's difficult
to eliminate that and successive regimes
have not been able to get rid of it and
people have aspired to it so I you know
while I think that the the road ahead is
going to be a difficult one
um I'm encouraged by the fact that there
is this sort of set there is this
political awareness uh among this new
generation of Iranians which is very
impressive and they've sort of learned
in a sense from the legacy of the past
which is the torture has been handed on
and it's not going to go anywhere so you
know ultimately I think you know there
is an opportunity but the key really for
the West is not to look a gift horse in
the mouth I mean the West has a terrible
terrible reputation for dropping the
ball you know on almost every occasion
so if for instance you know Iran does
move towards a secular system of
government and a democratic settlement I
should say that suits its own indigenous
sort of culture I don't want to
you know prescribe anything for them
whatever in that sense but let's say a
secular Republic of some sort
um I think it will be transformative in
the region in terms of Iran's relations
of the West in Iran's International
standing and this is something that the
West at the very least should not
obstruct
I put the bar very low there by the way
but you know even if we're not saying
encourage and I think it should
encourage it but what it shouldn't do is
obstruct it and you know there are
strong parallels here again with the
Ukrainian situation where we found if
you remember right at the beginning of
the invasion of Ukraine a number of
European countries very cynical very
skeptical do we really want to get into
this can't the Russians just get this
done quickly you know can we just move
on and so on and so forth
um again what I say to people about the
current protests in Iran is we don't
know I don't know where it's going to go
I mean anyone who says they can predict
it you know nonsense but I wouldn't
dismiss it so quickly either I mean
that's that's the key don't be so quick
to dismiss it these people are showing
enormous carriage and you know I think
they should be you know respected for
that and they should be given the space
in a sense to try and Achieve those aims
that you know most of us in the West
State for granted
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
Ali has this provoked a backlash against
the religion of Islam because people
associate the religion with this very
oppressive regime morality police Etc or
do people just see this as an example of
uh where you know Islam gone wrong to
put it mildly
I think there's both to be honest now
you know people want to be very careful
about so you know I always say that look
you know the secularism that that
Iranians are aspiring to is very much
you know what we would identify as an
anglo-american secularism
um rather than the French model you know
in that sense of layersism if I can put
it that way there's not you know
Iranians are always I in my view will
always have a tendency towards a
spirituality and have a religious belief
what they don't want however is the
government to be involved in religion
and they don't want the government to be
shoving religion you know right down
their throats and you know there are
arguments that basically you know in two
ways you know yes we have these clerics
we're a center of shiism in a sense as
as was said at the beginning of the the
podcast but you know very much like what
the Italians did to Catholicism you know
we ought to build a wall around the
religious cities they can do whatever
they want in the Vatican in Iraq you
know whatever but they shouldn't come
out the other side of it of course is is
goes to the heart again of what you were
saying there that um
you know when the revolution started
people would say that what we need to do
is we need to bring religion and
politics together we don't want to
divide religion and politics because
religion will make politics ethical and
of course many carricks at the time even
said that's not what's going to happen
what's going to happen is we're going to
make religion political and and we're
going to ruin it and that's basically
what's happened you know so basically
you know so what what they say is you
know I mean they used to say I don't
know if it's a very good analogy anymore
but they say you know look at the
Americans they have lots of religion
it's a secular Republic but they have
lots of religion
um I'm not sure that's the best
comparison to make these days but
nonetheless uh you know that's the point
the point is if you take politics out of
religion religion can flourish and it
can flourish in its purest form
right
um I have to say though you know going
back to what you were saying I think
there's a lot of young people who are
just completely fed up with religion
full stop
um now what what have they done in the
early 20 years ago I used to talk to
Iranians young Iranians and they were
turning towards Christianity for
instance they just didn't like they said
Islam is just they would say to me
actually they said it's a religion of
death they said you know all we do is
sort of celebrate Martyrs you know
um of course you know Christianity is
obviously built on the concept of
martyrdom because so you know but they
they seem to at least to see it it had a
uh you know there was hope built in that
but then also a lot of Iranians have
turned to various how should we say you
know um what I call Zoroastrianism with
house rules if I can put it that way I
mean they can't become zoroastrian in
that sense but they sort of feel this is
more authentically Iranian in terms of a
belief system and you know they you know
they will they will pursue religious
beliefs
um uh that suit them but they definitely
have a certain I think now the younger
generation certainly have a deep
antipathy towards what we would call
organized religion and in this case
obviously Islam in in Iran it will take
a long time for the for the religion
itself to re
establish itself if I can put it that
way as as something uh credible uh among
the young certainly
and we constantly talk about the young
people and it's obvious to you it's
always a young who yeah engage in
revolutions and and and have this
changed but what effect and what
influences the internet played upon
these young people are they looking at
apps like Instagram and Tick Tock and
seeing how we live in the west and going
hang on a second this person's allowed
to dress like this this person is
allowed to earn money this woman is
allowed to have to live the life that
she wants why am I not allowed that I
think that's absolutely right I mean I
think you know one of the reasons I say
to people we need to be very careful
about how we uh how we analyze the
current situation is because we're
operating in a very different
environment and that environment is
dictated by social media and the
internet and means of communication that
our ancestors even our very recent
forebears would not have been familiar
with
and technology has always played a very
pivotal role in Iran and political
movements from the foundation of the
telegraph through obviously to the radio
and you know cassettes and this sort of
thing and then obviously satellite uh
but this is something else and I I think
you're right about this it's very
difficult you know the Iranians Iranian
young people are particularly tech savvy
they understand the connectivity they
are connected by the way and you're
quite right you know they are connected
with the outside world they do see
things but more than that they see the
internet
and social media is a tool of
organization I mean that that's been
quite interesting and we don't see this
thing obviously we don't see this thing
because you know in a sense
as I say to people if we can see it then
surely the government can see it so you
know the the ideas a lot of this is
below the radar but there's there is as
I understand it an enormous amount going
on in in what you we could call you know
um you know parts of the web that are
that are hidden in some ways
um because they're there to protect
themselves and it is a it is a constant
battle obviously in Iran I mean the
government is is trying to close off
Avenues uh young people are opening up
other ones you know it's it's a running
back and I think one of the most
important things the West can do
actually in this is to ensure that the
internet stays in some way or form open
you know
um I don't know whether the starlink you
know that musk was talking about whether
that's functioning or not whatever but
you know we have to maintain uh channels
of communication because that's the way
they organize that's the way they
mobilize and uh I think it's been highly
effective and I on very much on that
point one of the I mean it's not a
criticism because you know criticizing
them but one of the concerns about How
likely the protesters are to succeed in
achieving their ends is that uh they
don't have an identifiable leader
there's no organizational structure uh
so even if they were able to somehow
Force the current regime out what does
it get replaced with that there's a lot
of concern that a they wouldn't be very
successful because they don't have an
organized structure and uh some kind of
leadership and B if they were to succeed
you know do you get some kind of mess
afterwards and then you end up with army
taking over or or something of that
nature I mean that that these are
distinct possibilities I mean yeah but
let's not have any Illusions about it
but where I would dispute with those
that get very obsessed with the absence
of leadership is that again we're
re-fighting 1979 rather than sort of
looking at broader political movements
in Iran 1906 had no single leader you
know had many different leaders uh many
coming from what we would call a
middling level not even you know higher
level now of course you know senior
clerics at times have come out and
support but often this occurred later
rather than earlier in anything and
you're already seeing these sort of
things in Iran by the way so you know
again if I think in due course I think
you're absolutely right to say that
there will need to be a greater a
sharpening in a sense of of the
organization the leadership it could be
many a few leaders by the way it doesn't
have to be a single leader
um but that would have to come where
what 10 weeks 11 weeks into a protest
cycle at the moment
I'm entirely prepared you know to see
that it would subside and then re-emerge
you know these things if you go back and
look at the period in 1979 78 I should
say if you look at the beard in 1906
there were lulls as well as sort of
you know increases in in Tempo and
activity and these things happen in
stages so I do say to people we ought to
be a little bit more cautious about the
fact that saying oh well there's no
clear leader there
um
there are no shortage of people who can
play the role of leader in Iran but I
mean there are no shortage of them the
very bright interesting people there and
I'm sure you know beneath the radar a
lot of them are are operating if you
look at the way in which uh the
government is set out sent out snatched
squads to pick off people on the streets
it's a clear indication that they
understand there are Street organizers
going on they may not be in the sort of
category of leader that you know people
sort of assume without
but as I remind people even in 1978 you
know not everyone so I to look Romania
as the primary leader I mean it took him
a while to consolidate his position uh
people rallied round him certainly
because they saw him as a potential
figurehead but not everyone saw him as
the lead to the revolution I mean that's
something that came later and I wanted
to ask you something uh perhaps slightly
unrelated and maybe even not in in terms
of your core hour expertise so feel free
to pass on it if you want there is in
light of the of the World Cup uh
currently happening in Qatar and our
attitudes to the way migrant workers are
treated yeah the way gay people are
treated women and so on there's
obviously a big debate and I am still
trying to chart a path for myself how I
feel about it because on the one hand uh
the moral relativism of oh yeah you know
it's just their culture let them throw
people off roofs and whatever yeah yeah
that that I find that upon on the other
hand do I feel that we in Britain should
decide how every country in the world
sets its laws and treats different
groups and you know again it seems
almost Colonial to some extent or
imperialistic to go in and say well you
must allow this to happen or you mustn't
allow this to be going on so how do we
how do we navigate that uh Ali when
we're dealing with cultures you know
these are ancient cultures with their
own ways of doing things that I I think
ought to be respected as well so how do
we how do we navigate this well I mean
the interesting thing is to root it in
that historical tradition and you're
absolutely right but if you look at
Iranians today as I said for two things
one is obviously these demands that they
have are rooted in political movements
going back to the 19th century but
they're also rooted in their own what I
consider to be a deep humanism that
actually transcends a lot of Iranian or
Persian culture through the centuries
you know this idea that you know let's
just let's just take the the case of
drinking you know alcohol are we really
assuming that in Iranian cultural
Persian culture nobody drank I mean you
know it over thousands of years people
have been drinking wine
um if you look at the role um even of
women if you look at yes there are
traditional aspects but it's also you
know what you're seeing in you know that
one of the great sort of myths I think
of the Islamic revolution is that
somehow they went back to the old order
now in some ways these are very radical
new interpretations it's a bit like you
know do you remember when when the
Taliban blew up the the Buddhas at
parmian and people said are they being
authentically Islamic and someone said
well what did the original Muslim
Invaders think I mean you know I mean
the fact is what they were doing was
being even more radical
than the original Muslims do you see
what I mean I mean and this is also a
question mark that's happened in Iran
now so there's Islamic revolution sorry
to interrupt just just simplify this so
the Islamic revolution isn't uh Iran
going back to its cultural heritage of
thousands of years it is in fact a
radical departure from those towards a
much more authoritarian
ultra-conservative Islam I mean I think
I think absolutely I mean I do you know
there is obviously a tradition of
autocracy in Iranian you know history of
course there is but you know democracy
and Republic fairly modern inventions in
that sense of development sometimes the
last couple hundred years
um but certainly even if you look at the
Iranian idea if you look at the ideology
of the Iranian Revolution they even say
in there they say we are going to
implement Islam as it should have been
implemented
do you see what I mean so they say
nobody else has done it we are the first
to do it so in a sense you know it's a
hugely hubristic position to take you
know that thousands of years nobody
understood it but we're going to do it
and so Islam has never been done
properly Ali exactly exactly and that's
what they say do you see what I mean so
they say you know what we're going to so
what I would say is you can easily look
at it and say actually this is a radical
departure
yeah and if you look at
um
uh even you know when I was working
heavily in the reform movement and
others in the 1990s and early in autism
because of shiism is a is interesting in
this regard because it relies on the
principle of continuous interpretation
of the scripture okay that's why you
have these mullers and clerics and
jurists and others they're constantly
looking at the scripture and
reinterpreting it for the time and of
course people would say then that in
terms of the veiling for instance you
know that there's nothing particularly
Islamic about the sort of veil and the
veil that Iran implements that you know
we need to interpret these things in
light of you know how Society moves
along so there was an interest in that
what the regime has done is basically
actually is is in some ways actually
extremely unislamic and and uh you know
I would say actually since 2009 a number
of things that they've done have aborted
I mean I think are actually quite
Blasphemous from an Islamic point of
view
um I mean I've talked to Muslims here
you know who say that they're quite
staggered by some of the claims they
make you know particularly in terms of
the supreme leader and his uh and the
authority he claims
um these are things these are things
that basically in traditional Shia you
know theology just you know are seen as
Innovative and Innovations of this sort
are actually very very uh uh frowned
upon
and Ali when I talked to uh one of my
Iranian friends he and I was putting
forward whilst I was doing research for
this interview and I was asking him
certain questions he said to me the
thing you need to understand France is
about Iranian culture is there is this
kind of Counter Culture that has always
existed within Iran and actually there's
a lot of people who when they want to go
and party young people they go to Tehran
because it's got this fantastic
underground party scene
well you know the joke in Iran you know
was always that you know before the
Revolution we used to you know pray
indoors and drink outdoors and then
after the revolution we uh you know
prayed outdoors and drank indoors I mean
it's it's that you know that there is a
sort of a
um uh Cosmopolitan uh iconoclastic
tradition certainly in Iran and and and
you know it's one of the things that's
allowed the regime to survive if I can
put it that way because for all the
autocracy there's a lot of sort of
crevices and and and ways in which you
can sort of navigate through and
actually live your life as you'd want to
uh as long as you're you know you
navigate that sort of thing uh carefully
um but of course as the regime has
become more and more autocratic and more
and more determined to impose its will
upon the population even those Avenues
are being shut down you see so then it
becomes incredibly difficult and it is
this point you know what I say to people
is I say you know why are people annoyed
why are people angry it's because you
know basically you have closed off every
opportunity for them
to have a bit of fun I mean you know to
be able to live their lives um your your
your suffocating the life out of them
and of course people are going to react
um and also I have to say you know the
memory of the last Revolution is now
fading a lot of people were horrified by
what the consequences of the first
Revolution were and weren't in a hurry
to have another one now the new younger
generation obviously have no memory of
revolution in 1979 and therefore are
less fearful if I can put it that one
and Ali is the reason that the regime
has become more autocratic is it is is
it just simply religious Doctrine or is
it because they can feel that power is
slowly slipping from their fingers so
they're trying to grip more tightly onto
it
I think it's just Uber essentially I
think power corrupts and and um you know
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
they just they've complacent in power
and they think they can just push the
limits further and further and further
so I think you know it it there is a
deep ideological strand within you know
the Hardline establishment where they
want to go and they are pushing that and
they are becoming more and more uh
despotic I think is the right word for
it really in terms of the pursuit of
this so I think that's uh uh it's it's
just an ideological project
well he's been absolutely fantastic
interview and thank you for uh this
incredible thank you uh into something
that we understand but you can imagine
as you can imagine we could probably go
on for hours but I don't think either
either you or your listeners would want
to I know I actually disagree I think
our listeners would have found this is
going to be very interesting and history
is actually one of the most popular
subjects on trigonometry we love it oh
really
Perhaps Perhaps Love to Get You On
another time but for now uh we have only
one more question for you which is as
always what is the one thing that we're
not talking about that we really should
be and that's a complete free hit
doesn't have to be related to Iran even
well you know what are we God you know
and since you've already warned me about
this in some ways but I have to say I I
can't think of anything at the moment
that I that I um I mean the one thing I
would say is and and this is completely
detached from what I've said but one of
the things I would say is I think we
need to um uh one of the things I think
we need to be very aware of
um certainly in the west is uh
I don't know if this is going to make
much sense actually I don't know if I
should let's find out so what I was
saying is that you know one of the
problems I found really is is is the um
uh the advance of the digital age and
our inability really to have regulated
moderated curated actually are digital
archives in a sense I you know one there
was a wonderful piece that one historian
put out and they said our failure to
actually deal with digital archives
means that in some ways we're entering a
new Dark Age and a dark age because
future historians are going to have this
blind spot in their archival resources
because many people have failed uh in a
sense to properly curate their digital
for archives and I know this is sort of
slightly left field but I think for
future historians it's going to be a
massive massive Problem by the way that
from about 2005 onwards it's going to be
a massive blind spot in terms of
um government and other sort of archives
that are simply not going to be
available because they have not been
properly curated
so I'm going to throw that out there I
know what people are going to make of it
but I I for me it's one of the great
problems that we're going to face going
forward and unless people tackle that
problem now it's it's it's it's going to
be quite interesting for the Next
Generation how they deal with recent
history
well that's fascinating we're going to
ask you a couple of questions from our
local supporters that only they will get
to see on locals uh but for now Ali I'm
sorry tell everybody where they can
follow uh your work if they wish to uh
they can they can follow me on they can
follow me on Twitter if they wish uh but
uh also just to keep an eye on on uh in
Savannah is actually on the San Andreas
website they can see stuff there and I'm
I'm I obviously do a few things on on
media and others so that's yeah yeah I
enjoyed the conversation you had with a
couple of our former guests recently
Nigel bigger ah yes yes I recommend
people check that out I have to go and
watch that you should it's good uh but
for now thank you so much for joining us
uh and thank you guys for watching uh
and listening we will see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one oral show all of which go out at 7pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it is also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
what would you say is the likelihood
that you're going to see a dramatically
new system of government
[Music]